[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
daniel germain has got a lot of things
going on he's taking time for us he's
one of the most respected analysts that
you have covering the nfl nfl network
analyst also works for the chargers on
radio you can follow the nfl network's
coverage of the 2022 nfl draft from
vegas tonight kicks off at eight eastern
first round with your host rich eisen
daniel jeremiah joins us daniel thanks
for joining us the team you're most
curious about tonight is
well i'm gonna say the texans dan uh
nobody knows anything about this draft
period but like you really know nothing
about the texans in terms of what they
can do so we assume we're going to see
some combination of of walker hutchinson
one two uh there's some buzz maybe
thibodeau gets in the mix there at two
but at three literally they could go in
any direction nobody has a clue what the
texans are going to do
and i wondered if you know they take a
flyer on derrick stingley uh
that high you hear that yeah you hear
that i mean that's one of the one of the
things you hear i'm always just
skeptical
and i take i give houston the same
treatment that i give the patriots which
is you can say you're hearing something
but when somebody never talks it's
literally impossible to hear something
well
it's like we're trying to figure out
what we think they could be thinking
without hearing from anybody
um exactly give me the player that is
dangerous as far as boy it could be
uh feast or famine it could be hall of
fame or bust
well i think you just hit it i think
stingley is the interesting one because
well you know we've said it throughout
this process dan you go back to 2019
he's unbelievable it would have been a
lock top five pick who's outstanding
and i know this last year let's just
talk about 2021 well
i'm going to throw that completely out i
kind of dinged him on that initially
ucla game was was not good it was
terrible and then you find out he gets
he hurts his foot a couple games later
and then he's done for the season well i
found out after the fact that that foot
had been bothering him since august so
i'm going to throw out 20 20 81 but then
i go back to 2020 and that's the
in-between season and and he was not a
great year in 2020 devonte smith you
know went off against him that's a real
legit receiver um and that's part of the
deal playing in the sec you're gonna see
real big time dudes but uh you know
that's that's something that's
concerning you're gonna take a guy up
there in the top five and there's some
uh there's some tape out there that's
not great
yeah i loved him as a freshman i said to
coach oh you know he could win the
heisman you could have him play offense
and defense i mean i thought that highly
of him and then i thought you're going
against jamar chase in practice every
day
how could you not be ready for this
moment
but you know sauce gardner of cincinnati
feels like that's a safer pick smarter
pick uh let me get to the jets and the
giants you have two picks each in the
top ten
what direction would you go let's start
with the jets
yeah with the jets um you know they need
difference making players like some
skill position players i'm all for
building up the line of scrimmage you
know go get your offensive alignment uh
i'm into that but dan if
you know if you tried to
pull the normal average football fan of
who the starting right tacticals were
for the two teams in the super bowl last
year i don't think they tell you
to me you've got to have some guys that
can make plays on the football
offensively or defensively so sauce
gardener to me
he can take the football away he gives
them a pure number one corner and you
kind of look about how they could change
their defense they go out and sign dj
reading free agency who's a good corner
now you bring in sauce gardener so last
year you know bryce hall is your number
one corner now he's your number three
corner now you've got depth all the way
down through that secondary so that
would be the first area i would look
with that first pick and then the second
pick you know i'm trying to try to help
out your quarterback you know if you can
get garrett wilson that's the home run
pick for me if he gets the 10
if not drake london gives you a little
something different with some size to
help out your quarterback so that's the
area i would go with the jets and then
when you look at the giants um you know
i can i can make a case they should go
offensive lineman receiver they have a
lot of needs you can go in any direction
so if you have your choice why not just
build up one side of the ball get a fair
evaluation on daniel jones figure out
this next year if he's the guy or not
and then you can move forward as an
organization it feels like if somebody's
moving up they're moving up to take a
wide receiver
so i think there's a chance that
philadelphia tries to come up for
garrett wilson uh i think there's a
chance that houston could try and come
up for garrett wilson i wouldn't sleep
on the saints you know i was talking to
a gm last night then he brought up a
great point which is are we all just
taking the saints at their word you know
they made that weird trade with the
eagles you know for a pick in the middle
of the first round you know weeks in
advance of the draft which just is one
of the more odd trades that you're ever
going to see
and uh you know i did my mock draft last
night and i had them taking you know i
think i had him taking a receiver and a
tackle and this gm said how does it make
sense that you part with a future one
and a future two so that you can come
away with a receiver and a tackle that
just doesn't make any sense to me
whatsoever um so that's kind of one of
the intriguing teams to follow tonight
maybe they've been sandbagging us maybe
they are going to take a quarterback
yeah i tell people all the time if i was
in a position of being a gm or an owner
i'm not going to tell anybody anything
i'm not going to be truthful to the
media now somebody in a house may leak
some information but i would never tell
the media like carolina hey
you know we uh we we told sam darnold we
may take a quarterback okay
i would i wouldn't tell like what's the
benefit of of saying that unless you
think somebody's gonna go oh
if we want a quarterback we better go
and jump in front of carolina
so true story i i was talking to some
teams picking in the top ten and
literally with within one hour they told
me hey you know i think the carolina
panthers would like to move up ahead of
the giants to guarantee they get the
first tackle and then within an hour
report came out that they have let sam
darnold know that they might take a
quarterback in other words like complete
hey just know we might take a
quarterback we might really do it uh and
then maybe somebody jumps in front of
you then guess who would fall to them if
somebody took a quarterback right in
front of them the tackle yeah i don't i
don't believe anything there's a
quarterback bet we have in-house here
paulie my producer says
that there will be at least one
quarterback taken in the first 13 picks
uh i'm going to say no
but in a year where we don't know
anything i wouldn't say my confidence
level is high i don't think there's a
you know i i wouldn't sleep on the
saints potentially where they are with
those two picks in the teams i think the
pittsburgh steelers you know i think
there's a high probability that they
take one but i you know six eight nine
panthers falcons seahawks i just i don't
think they're gonna do it
daniel jeremiah nfl network analyst nfl
networks coverage starts tonight at
eight eastern first round
if jordan love was in this draft
where would he rank
oh my gosh dan we're going to the way
back machine here uh you know
just talent and tools wise i think he'd
probably be
you know i think he would be it would be
a fun discussion with him and malik
willis just in terms of of guys with you
know kind of some impressive raw tools
and malik quills could be the first
quarterback taken so he'd have been
right there in the mix now it's been a
long time since he was coming out and i
don't think his values gone up at all
with the little bit that we've seen him
play it's gone down more than anything
else so um you know this this jordan
love version now would probably be in
the you know the three or the four role
okay but i was wondering about this and
and we were discussing this as a group
prior to the show if you're a team that
you know has a third fourth round pick
and you didn't get the quarterback you
wanted in the first or second round and
you just called up the packers and said
hey
we'll take jordan love off your hands
it's worth a flyer it's worth a flyer
but man i would have liked to have done
that a little earlier just because
you're all the benefits of the rookie
contractor you're getting ready to
expire before too long on jordan love as
you get further down the road but he's
not even 24 yeah daniel
no no you've got you've got a you've got
some raw tools to uh to work with and
develop so you've got an opportunity
there i love it while you're while we're
talking an agent where does my guy go i
don't know i don't know where he goes uh
those are the text messages that come in
on on the morning then but uh no i think
that's i think it's a legit that's a
it's legit point you know if you can
part with a fourth round pick and take a
flyer on a quarterback if you don't have
one uh why not
and then you got debo samuel you got
baker mayfield
um
who's more likely to be traded this
weekend debo or baker
the debo thing's been a roller coaster i
mean from being told there's no chance
that that happens to oh you know they
would do it um if it was the right price
and then then you hear oh my gosh the
prices they're asking for is ridiculous
i mean they want two ones there's no way
they're getting two ones um and then and
then it was you know
it doesn't look likely as of as where we
are right now that that's gonna happen
and then the baker thing i think that's
going to probably be determined on what
you know what happens in the first round
if these teams all pass um then i think
there's more of the likelihood that
something with baker gets done by the
end of the draft but they're going to
have to eat a lot of money dan but
they're going to eat a big chunk of that
thing
yeah but they got to move on because it
it they can't help you know you're
you're bringing into sean watson who's
already polarizing then you can't have
baker in camp you you just no i don't
think there's any way that he he is
there in camp but just a matter of
whether it actually happens during the
draft or whether it's a little bit after
that
great to talk to you have fun tonight
i'll try not to text you
oh no dan i love the text man are you
kidding me i know but i try to be
professional because when i told people
that i text you when you were on last
time and then they're like is that being
professional and i thought you know
maybe it's not
so
no
i mean i've got i've got literally the
best life coach in media so i mean why
would i not tap into that resource you
know what i'll do
i'll text you during the commercial
breaks
okay okay that's great and by the way
for fritzy you know there's there's some
defensive events in this draft where we
say
you know they've asked them to read
they've asked them to think they're
better off when you just cut them loose
and put them on the edge no
responsibilities just go that's that's
that's fritzy's role on the show
wow
so an edge is he my my kayvon thibodeaux
no i was gonna say more like a guy like
boye mafe you know who you know at
minnesota they ask him do a lot of
things he goes to the senior bowl they
just widen them out and tell him to get
up the field and you wreck shop at its
best reed is a four-letter word for
fritzy okay gotcha okay that's helpful
advice did he call me why do they just
dance i think he said why he took a
little shot there i i need to lose about
20 25 but come on it's drafting there's
nothing to do with that
and daniel
can can we have a body good player could
we have a uh a
high motor attached to a black player
tonight instead of just aiden hutchinson
can we do that because i think thibodeau
has a high motor just you know
okay yeah so i would say i would say
trayvon walker has a higher vote so i
might go that first pick right out the
gate i like that if you say you know
what i love about him you got a high
motor that's all i love it yeah it's
good i love it i love it yeah uh thank
you and i'm going to say that garrett
wilson's just gritty and an overachiever
oh i like that that'll be good
thank you daniel that's daniel jeremiah
nfl network analyst one of the sharper
guys covering this sport